guess what
he was gone to mourn his dad for two
weeks
but he's not going he he's back
he is back dude
[Music]
so
now he's not on
he's not on uh
he's not in an active volcano yet or
anything so they let him come back into
the studio you know to get his bearings
again
and I be let me see here
here he is all right
all right we got a couple things from
him today you're gonna love him the
artist her who is revealing another side
to herself as the star of Beauty and the
Beast a 30th celebration and um welcome
to the show great to see you thank you
great to see you and I want to do
something different that I I've never
done I don't think most yo we're doing
this again remember with the other one
the chick from Avatar on the same is
this a new thing where girls were
talking head suits and then and then pay
heels
what's going on with the style why do
why are women all dressing like Paula
Poundstone on the top and Scarlett
Johansson on the bottom I guess this is
the new thing that's two gay Jewish guys
are pushing in fashion worlds this year
those people knew to do with calling us
you Gabriella Wilson yes and you think
it's important for people to know your
your real name now why is that you know
it's it's really that I I've really been
finding refining my voice and I think
what does that means he finally
explained SEO to me and why am I getting
very many impressions
you're right hurt Eminem is her that's a
really good point look her is very
common it is [ __ ] you up we're gonna
need something the only the only the
only person who had a more angrier SEO
manager is when Prince changed his name
to a symbol that guy must have been
Furious what am I supposed to do with
this I can't do anything with this
there's not a letter in it they had to
send out to all of like the music
magazines and [ __ ] they had to send them
a floppy disk with a font file that just
had that symbol in it so they could
write his name
you're right because it didn't come with
Word Perfect back then
not wearing glasses I can't be acting
and wearing glasses so I think if you
can't what it's time for people to
really get to know the person behind her
you know and nobody
cares hers me but at the same time it's
like
it's just a
it's a it's a new chapter in my life and
I think I'm really bro these people are
filled with such self-importance like
you said you know man we all have people
who like go through a lot of [ __ ] and
people that are really struggling right
now and then you hear this woman like
I've been like super famous but I
thought like I'm really sick of my name
so I just had a new chapter in my life
and it's like God you people [ __ ] are
insufferable oh yeah this is the chick I
made all that money off of on the
Grammys yep that's the one yeah this is
that chick she's hot though you know
finding that connection and allowing
people to yeah she's the one that did
like the black lives matter song or
whatever
I can't breathe song and I made like
[ __ ] I got like a 400 and something
dollar payoff on that cha-ching yeah and
I only bet like 40 bucks it was like one
of those weird 20 to 1 long shots and
I'm like watch I was like the [ __ ]
verdict's coming soon it all just was a
perfect storm I'm like nobody's talked
about this song all year but they're
gonna give it a Grammy so that now the
song blows up just in time for the
verdict and I was like boom and a bunch
of other people won money too on that
that's great thank you thank you her
what's her name now uh it's Kim because
that's already Billy valo's gonna sue
you man Gabriel Wilson
you brought up earlier her is not the
best for SEO
no it's not I remember like when she
would because she used to have a cup she
actually had some pretty good r b songs
when I was like she was around when I
was
um doing strip clubs in the club it was
hard to find like some of her [ __ ]
sometimes like like where she said
because it's like that's a weird thing
to search for
a little bit you know and I'm in a
commercial break Catherine let me get
this straight you're her but am I him
so how does that work
now I'm going to put I'm new to this
stuff is that they were together hanging
out would we be us
or maybe them are we will be they them
I'm new to this pronoun thing
[Laughter]
I don't know how to do this
so you so you get real now but she was
the hurt are you still at her
or are you changing genders too because
I'm very confused by the basically the
entire Direction this country is going
in the last time I had they made me clap
and a little a little boy named Desmond
who was a girl or something I'm a little
confused I'm very confused by the
direction the country's going in but I'm
also a nice guy and I don't want to
offend nobody yeah exactly so I don't
want to rock the boat too much I just
don't want to ask any questions that are
offensive but I want to also make sure
that I'm being sensitive to everybody's
needs
even that Kelly Ripa who was the real
[ __ ] to me
you know I'd rather just be in space can
I go back to space
Jones I think that's all he thinks about
yes he dreams of just being [ __ ] he
just zones out during the [ __ ]
tapings down they're like Mike and he's
like what yeah I was thinking about
space
being in that penis rocket with Jeff
Bezos was the comet I've ever been I
need to make friends with Elon Musk I
have so much talent in one in person and
now we all get a chance to see your
other side of your talent and the acting
side of it because you will be the first
Black and Filipino Bell oh that's why
she's hot and [ __ ] Frozen
that makes sense is she half of your
people
is she is she not accepted by either
side
is she like blade
um she clamming us she's the first black
vampire or Filipino Bell and Filipino
Bell I'm sorry was is that is that a
thing or yes how did that make you feel
what does that mean to you oh my gosh
you have no idea the timing of it all
you nailed it that's why she's so pretty
though huh that's that's the that's a
good mix that is a good mix they're
calling her a [ __ ] Pino in the chat
okay you can't call her dad
foreign
I call her a Filipino
it's just a dream come true like I never
thought I could be a Disney princess of
course every little neither did we but
here we are
yeah we even hoped for it but listen
it's fine and you guys listen I'm very
happy for you you know it's Beauty and
the Beast you get to play Belle in
what's going to end up being like the
fourth most watched version of Disney's
Beauty and the Beast and nobody's gonna
care no no it's just just Times Square
performance she's not even going to be
oh that's all so you're not even in a
movie oh
yeah but you saw Splash Mountain is
closing January 27th here because of the
Song of the South is racist the movie
they based it off of and it's going to
be replaced by you know black princess
Bayou Alligator Adventure whatever the
[ __ ] movie was what was what was the
Bayou movie virtue you got kids what was
the Bayou movie though the one with the
black princess
and the frog princess and the frog yeah
they're turning into a purchase of the
Frog ride I was close that's less racist
I was close whatever because that wasn't
terrifying it's Voodoo we have all the
same mechanics it'll be the same ride
we'll just have to go to ooga booga
mountains yeah this is a good book about
another good point yeah
oh no we're gonna go over the didn't do
nothing Falls
[Laughter]
this is the 1350 Ravine but they still
keep all the racist music from
nothing
the water merch I think this is Old
English no it's Kool-Aid actually
um Kool-Aid and Old English there's
different people oh yes you know what
that you know what that you know you
know what that's called that's called
the gur mimosa
um let's continue
but you know I've never seen one that
that looks like me yes we've seen a
dozen in the last two years yeah please
get out of here all right and you're not
the first Blasian I've ever seen either
so let's [ __ ] hold your horses okay
just because you look just because just
because look she she looks like
a Thai horror was left out in the sun
too long I don't know how to say that
mean like nicer I don't know the nicer
way to say that no I'm being serious
okay she looks like the backup dancer of
an Aaliyah video
so I get to be that you know to little
girls my [ __ ] thing was nicer yeah I
think you're right and that's such a
huge deal on top of being a producer on
Beauty and the Beast which is crazy I
got to oh you're a producer too huh they
just give that to anybody huh
no do a lot of the new Arrangements yeah
dude Good Morning America is an
unprofessional [ __ ] show are you kidding
me do you think that they have any sort
of quality control There Anymore Michael
Strahan is an is a news anchor now are
you kidding me
oh by the way you saw the girl that
spiked the story the one that's on Good
Morning America and the black dude from
the from from the show are were caught
like you know apparently they've been
[ __ ] and now they're out in the open
about it that's a whole thing yeah uh
uh
okay
gosh I was like what
I got to oh hold on
and this is of course that new modern
twist we have in the song which is
called please leave this neighborhood
and um and then we have we have another
one called the property values are going
down am I really the Beast and that's
another good one yes yes yes
oh [ __ ]
um
foreign
I got to unlock a new thing Within
Myself and that's why I say the timing
is so great
um yeah my inner Disney princess which I
think is this fearless and uh joyful and
but since it's like a Black Beauty and
the Beast like all the candelabras and
everything are locked behind security
glass like at a Walgreens
yes
all the glassware it's not even nice
it's all like stuff from Dollar Tree or
it's like collectible cups from Burger
King
wakanda forever collectible plastic cups
black panther too rinsed out rinsed out
Slurpee cups and [ __ ]
oh man there's a musical scene where two
half empty bottles of Arizona Iced Tea
sing it's really really yeah
and just strong and uh kind of kind of
Brave uh thing within within myself I'm
finding so it's been it's been a crazy
wonderful experience and you're all
about the music too so what is your
favorite song from Beauty and the Beast
oh my gosh I think my favorite song
might be the opening song Belle because
it's when you first meet her and it's
the first the only one I know right
because I just started learning the song
so it's the first one but because it's
it's the black one instead of her
walking around the village reading books
and saying how much she likes reading
books it's her with talking about her
audible subscription so it's still
pretty cool
we got more about how much she loves to
listen to music loudly on our smartphone
yes yes but speaking of audible
subscription do I have something for you
somebody wrote a book
entertainment just
[Music]
oh my God I'm Michael Strahan for decade
and a half I'm the defensive end for the
New York Giants
[ __ ] amazing I hold the record for
the most sacks in a single season and
help the Giants win Super does he still
hold that record yes [ __ ] yeah good for
Michael freehand against a [ __ ] he
was a vicious animal on the field I
think people we always forget we have to
keep reminding the audience that this is
not the Michael Strahan we grew up with
we we grew up with Michael Strahan
getting [ __ ] carted off the
field bro he was a machine and it's have
you ever seen if you ever want to have
if you ever want to have fun actually
here's a good one
um and I always want to point out too
that he played at a time when like the
sport was played by men
yeah if you ever want here you go I got
one for you
ever seen his we're on local so we could
do it you ever seen this mic'd up
no
you
know
I like your day everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you know I love this guy man he
was even fun back yeah oh yeah when he
look off the feet yeah even with him
he's on the field he'll kill you here
let's see who we watch right now here
you can't [ __ ] with me
[Laughter]
straight hand's the kind of guy that
would [ __ ] hit you like a truck
almost break your hip and then probably
help you up thought about that you okay
man okay come on get up I was just say
you're real good actually I just met him
it was trash talk earlier I hope this
one I hope this has the one where he
tells him he's gonna put his ass in the
ground next time oh yes yes yeah no no
this this is [ __ ] hilarious
it don't work over here dude it don't
work over here dude I love him
he's on the left you gotta go get him
over there I'm trying to help him out
there hey
I love this guy man
you gotta go the other way man you gotta
go the other way you know they did a
miked episode he gotta go the other way
man
I'm trying to help you man out
[Applause]
I just lost my freaking mind for a
second
but it's definitely worth watching bro
it's so funny
um I'll tell you gotta go the other way
you gotta go the other way